okay okay guys
we are continuing the star food okay
take a color what okay
brilliant i'm gonna do this sometime oh
cause you're you're guaranteed to be
white if i'm playing a staff right now
okay yeah okay good luck yes let's go oh
yeah okay
yes oh okay
yes let's go stafford again at this time
i feel like you you've actually studied
this opening i'm like
well we'll see what happens yeah yeah
it's cool i just
know what bird traps i should not fall
into yeah let's be greedy i think vidit
would be very proud of moving on to your
con
ah okay let's see we are already
yeah i think this is okay okay okay
all good live streams yeah you're
playing safe
yeah but because like the object of the
game
is to demoralize eric before it's next
game
like after this game you should be
thinking wait i don't want oh no
my gambit i don't want the secrets to be
out there how to demolish
me eric should be like oh no my gambit
is just gone
i think eric's already there all it
takes
is one bad game
don't say that too soon no the thing
about trash talk is people are like
oh what if i do the trash talk and then
then i don't win
i'm like i don't care about that i'll do
the trash talk as long as you trash talk
on your own time i'm completely happy
but yeah eddie is this amazing
grandmaster
who is also awesome with content okay
now
ah it's time to show eric's french
what it takes to be a beast what it
takes to
wow so you're gambling back yeah yeah
that's kind of reckless
yeah but this is how we roll
like a bowling ball
yeah it's jokes you can never guess
what's coming
yes oh no my pawn i kind of want to take
it
yeah everyone is greedy nowadays greedy
everyone is that greedy i kind of don't
want to take it
okay i am getting distracted
distracted by what nothing just
breathtaking
okay now he is toast guys he's
completely toast
he will not have any hope left in life
i'm a pawn
i'm up i look for it official threat is
better than execution
that's true but winning is better than
losing
okay now what's happening
yeah it's very pretty yeah it's okay you
mean the breathtaking view of the staff
at cambridge
everything
okay now what do we do i wouldn't have
done that
i've taken the group really god it just
cute down i didn't want to double all my
pawns
they just keep developing this is great
life
okay now his king is permanently going
to be on here
but eric is playing uh no castling chess
he's supposed to play that
it's not like he has a choice what's
castle
eric a castle is like oh i can't
demonstrate legally unfortunately
i would love to show you does that even
exist
you'll have to use your imagination
uh oh this this is i can show you what's
not castling
that is what you're showing your every
game
okay now i'm just trying some
oh i think this game is going to be a
masterpiece i'm
already scared but hopefully it's a
masterpiece in my
favor and eric you know who what your
mistake was
starting the game yeah choosing me as
your operand oh
okay well inviting you to come over with
us
okay this was yeah i guess still it's
fun
just let's demoralize eric your bishops
are preventing all of mine
my writings don't want to do in life no
hope
i can already imagine the title of the
video getting killed by the indian
bishops
it's not comfortable just now you
realize that
i'm realizing it more and more
i just want to trade with you oh this is
not a bad idea thank you
but it's not good enough
okay what do we do so many ways to
continue okay let's just keep the pieces
i am coming for you eric
okay now it's gonna be so much fun
yeah let's be greedy oh eric
oh no oh no oh no
yeah it's really hard no okay should i
play for audience
of course okay always
always go for the show the show must go
on
this is what actually maria told me
before the game
i think that was the even the strongest
moves
that's oh yes now guys it's time for
picking the brilliancy
okay i don't know why but okay it's fine
still we are winning
better late than never
what do i even do here yeah it's so
difficult oh my god i can't
oh yes let's just push
no it's not bad until it is bad
oh yes i think i know what to do
yeah okay what is this
so many days to win take your time
yes let's let's do this
oh finally you found the right moment
today
yeah okay i think i'm completely missing
keep it going keep it going
now what are we doing okay fine i'll
just take
this pawn there's no need to do this off
okay let's bring the rope where he
cannot attack
okay
oh okay fine i have to show something
i cannot believe it came to this oh now
you're being greedy
wait it is very similar to my game
okay y'all okay let's just
okay let's see if he wants
don't hurt me
don't hurt me okay
great oh my god it's actually losing
i'm waiting oh yeah
someone to protect you or to
weaken your opening it's such a sweet
analogy
being
this has gone so bad so
eric do you want to continue of course
okay how did i not win this
yeah this video has gone on for so long
we have to do some multiple mini clips
okay
guys this is the price you pay for
blundering for being coffee yes
it was growing quite well i don't know
that it
yeah okay yes okay yeah
yeah the show must go on i like knight
but it was a fun game
night decent yeah and then before you
took planet f2
oh 97 yeah it's probably
losing but it looked fun yeah
because no actually after that i didn't
see a clear win actually it was funny
i really thought i'm just kidding no i
thought i was a porno when i played
queenie
actually yeah oh yeah it was funny
okay yes at least i tied
that's great um be sure to check out
aliban bhaskaran
on youtube i'll link his instagram his
whatever what else do you mind
start with twitter yeah all the links in
the description
um we had special guest commentary from
srinath if you want to show your face
real quick
thank you guys yeah and then jesus
okay and stay tuned for more comments